it doesn't matter
99% of things don't matter how do you
allow yourself to look at the small
things like somebody has a nicer car
there's somebody has more followers on
Instagram it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter that your boss is suppressing you
because she or he is flawed and insecure
and will block you from the next step it
doesn't matter you know why it doesn't
matter because you're in control you're
more than welcome to take a step back to
sell your pot to sell you home to go
rent from a worse apartment to buy one
less pair of shoes it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you get these enough
so you know why because when real life
kicks that [ __ ] doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if your
sister's winning or losing it doesn't
matter if your best friend's making
$100,000 a year and you haven't figured
out who you are it doesn't matter
my friends the only thing that matters
is how to judge yourself inside your
head and do you understand where you're
going and how you're gonna do it and how
long you have to get there because all
the things that are being thrown at you
on a daily basis that make you judge
yourself in the short-term don't matter
literally 99% of my answers to my
management team my best friends the ones
I care about the most and why during
this project that is pouring out of me
given clarity and an ease that I
struggle to even though I am and always
will be a communicator
I have to put this down on film tape
video it just doesn't matter do you
understand
literally every single thing that you
can come up with right now to tell me
why not
why you can't why you were dealt the
short straw why it's not meant to be
forward here all those artificial doubts
that were poured into your brain by your
inner circle and your outer game don't
matter
please watch this video everyday anytime
something sucks like [ __ ] remember it
doesn't matter in the macro there are
only so few things that you will think
about on your deathbed there are only so
few things that will matter to you as
you continue to drive and guide through
your life so understand whatever [ __ ]
you're upset about right now
fundamentally doesn't matter
it just doesn't so he broke up with you
to tease a [ __ ] loser so your boss
told you suck they suck so your business
failed you sucked you couldn't figure it
out pick yourself up get a job become
practical and go back out in three years
if that's what you are it all doesn't
matter in the end what matters is did
you do it your way did you die and your
sword did you do it on your feet
did you listen to yourself
and did you do it the right way
we will all be exposed at the end we
will all be naked at the end an
understanding that it does not matter as
long as you're doing it the right way
and not allowing yourself to value
somebody else's opinion or to sense over
your own and understanding that many
fans booth in the third quarter of a
game that a team wins every night
do not be crippled by the short turn
narrative do not be crippled by the
short term narrative based on things
that do not matter I did not allow my
grades my circumstance the judgment that
I was working at my daddy's liquor store
at 28 and woe is him none of those
things matter in the same way that I
don't let the headlines and the covers
of the magazines and the admirations for
this project to allow me to get anywhere
outside my house to get to allow me to
get anywhere outside my head how I'm
gonna do this for how long and in what
way
is that the other day just doesn't
matter